[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute
hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem montag
die vom sport hat norbert lehmann als
wunderanzug vor mir und wir haben unter
anderem diese themen für sie
die regierung in der ukraine krise nach
internationalen vorwürfen gegenüber
russland zu zögerlich vorzugehen beraten
führende politiker der spd über ihren
kurs
bluttat bei verkehrskontrolle in der
westpfalz werden eine 24-jährige
polizeianwärterin und ihr 29 jähriger
kollege erschossen zwei tatverdächtige
sind gefasst
und überlebenskampf bei minusgraden nach
starken schneefällen in syrien wird die
not hunderttausende vertriebene familien
immer größer
nicht nur das ausland runzelt die stirn
über die haltung deutschlands im ukraine
konflikt die bundesrepublik müsse
russland viel stärker unter druck setzen
fordern vor allem osteuropäische länder
die union spricht von einer unklaren
linie der regierung und selbst die
kanzlerpartei spd ist in sich gespalten
heute lud parteichef klingbeil zum
klärungsgespräch aus berlin david guetta
es soll bloß ein arbeitstreffen sein
thema der russland ukraine konflikt in
großer einheit wird beteuert und doch
zwischen den zeilen kann man den riss
ahnen zwischen einem großen teil der
basis und fast der gesamten ost spd und
der regierungs spd im bund wenn die
sozialdemokratischen teile der
bundesregierung sprechen wenn die spd
führung spricht wenn die spd
bundestagsfraktion spricht dann ist klar
die aggression geht von russland aus
wenn andere in der spd sprechen klingt
das mitunter ganz anders exponierte
vertreter ex-kanzler ex-spd-chef und
aktuell gazprom lobbyist gerhard
schröder kritisiert in einem podcast
nicht aggression aus russland sondern
der ukraine und ich hoffe sehr dass man
endlich auch das säbelrasseln in der
ukraine
wirklich einstellen äußern können sich
viele aber entscheidend tun wir als
aktuelle spd-führung gemeinsam mit
bundeskanzler olaf scholz
und noch mal da sind wir völlig klar die
eskalation geht von russland aus wir
sind völlig klar dass alle optionen auf
dem tisch liegen vom tisch innerhalb der
spd sind waffenlieferungen an die
anfragen der ukraine schritte jedoch die
frage möglicher russland sanktionen wie
das aus der umstrittenen ostseepipeline
nord stream 2 ein projekt mit dem
manchen der spd eng verbunden sind der
grüne koalitionspartner mahnt
geschlossenheit anderen fordert dass wir
uns alle bemühen dass die zwischentöne
auch einhellig sind auch von anderen
akteuren denn alle diese töne werden im
ausland wahrgenommen und das ist keine
hilfe für die aussenministerin oder für
den kanzler wenn
draußen das gefühl entsteht die
deutschen werden sich nicht einig die
spd als kanzlerpartei zwischen neuer
regierungsverantwortung und alten
verbundenheit
unter laub energy in berlin kann da eine
sitzung tatsächlich mehr geschlossenheit
bringen also das dürfte schwierig werden
es ist nicht zu erwarten dass jetzt nach
diesem treffen die spd komplett auf
einer linie ist das kann auch gar nicht
in der sache seinem parteien sind auch
dazu da um meinungsverschiedenheiten
auszutragen auch einmal öffentlich aber
klar ist dass sich der gastgeber lars
klingbeil hier bemüht um eine
einheitliche linie die er ja auch in den
vergangenen tagen immer wieder betont
hat er hat immer wieder gesagt die
parteiführung diejenigen die
verantwortlich sind sie sind sich einig
und haben auch russland immer wieder
eindeutig kritisiert für provokationen
und sich auch für sanktionen
ausgesprochen sollte es denn nötig
werden aber er hat eben zu kämpfen mit
prominenten stimmen in der partei
gerhard schröder haben wir gerade eben
gehört den ex-bundeskanzler arbeit auf
der anderen seite zum beispiel auch
sigmar gabriel den ex parteivorsitzenden
das sind stimmen die heutzutage in der
spd nicht mehr mit entscheiden aber
natürlich in der öffentlichen
wahrnehmung immer noch großes gewicht
haben auch andere die heutzutage noch
mit diskutieren sind dabei also er muss
sich darum bemühen dieses bild zusammen
führt zu führen das wird er heute auch
noch einmal tun in dieser runde und hat
dazu ebenfalls politiker eingeladen aber
eben auch stimmen wie manuela schwesig
aus mecklenburg vorpommern die sich ja
immer wieder sehr kritisch geäußert hat
zu möglichen sanktionen
das ist eine runde in der es heute darum
geht auch den kanzler in wenig
rückendeckung zu verschaffen wenn er
getragen von der parteiführung
drohszenarien auch einmal vorsichtig
formuliert in richtung russland das die
dann nicht gleich von der partei wieder
eingerissen werden
dankeschön für diese einschätzung aus
berlin chuck unterleib energy die
ukraine krise war heute auch thema im un
sicherheitsrat in einer öffentlichen
sitzung beantragt durch die usa die us
botschafterin und andere staaten
verlangten von russland seine 100.000
soldaten an der ukrainischen grenze
zurückzuziehen russland wies das zurück
und warf dem westen österreichs vor der
vorwurf moskau plane einen einmarsch sei
falsch
hierzulande ist der schock groß über den
polizistenmord in rheinland pfalz ein 29
jähriger beamter und seine 24 jährige
kollegin sind bei einer
verkehrskontrolle erschossen worden zwei
mutmaßliche täter sind inzwischen
gefasst die beiden polizeibeamten waren
in der nacht im kreis kusel in der nähe
von kaiserslautern im einsatz eine
gewöhnliche streifenfahrt auf der
kreisstraße 22 zwischen ulm it und mai
weiler hof kontrollierten sie ein
verdächtiges fahrzeug dann fielen
schüsse kanada und mario geiger
berichten zwei junge polizisten sterben
durch schüsse an dieser kreisstraßen der
westpfalz eine 24 jährige kommissar
anwärterin und ihr 29 jähriger kollege
sie kontrollierten einen wagen konnten
per funk noch durch geben dass schüsse
fallen dieser mann soll einer der täter
sein der 38 jährige andreas s aus dem
saarland am frühen abend wird er im
saarländischen sulzbach festgenommen
kurze zeit später fassen
spezialeinheiten der polizei einen 32
jährigen verdächtigen
die beamten stellen beweismittel sicher
darunter auch waffen die bluttat in der
westpfalz erschüttert die bundespolitik
bundesinnenministerium nennt sie
vertritt hat
unabhängig vom motiv diese tat erinnert
an eine hinrichtung und zeigt dass
polizei jeden tag leben für unsere
sicherheit riskiert meine gedanken sind
bei den familien freunden und kollegen
der opfer wir werden alles tun um die
täter dingfest zu machen die flaggen in
rheinland pfalz auf halbmast die
landesregierung zeigt sich zutiefst
schockiert
ich bin sehr erschüttert und ich bin mit
meinen gedanken bei den angehörigen und
freunde und freundinnen der
polizeibeamtinnen und polizeibeamten die
heute nachts heute morgen bei einer
routineüberprüfung portals ermordet
worden sind weil die polizei angreift
greift uns alle an die polizei setzte
die ermittlungen fort durchsucht jetzt
mehrere objekte weitere tatverdächtige
sei nicht ausgeschlossen
zu corona jetzt da hatte die neue
bundesregierung ja ehrgeizige ziele
formuliert 80 prozent der bevölkerung
sollten mindestens einmal geimpft sein
bis heute das ziel wurde verfehlt auch
deshalb sagt die regierung weil man die
impfbereitschaft überschätzt habe
christoph des tor in hamburg in statt
weniger los als sonst vielleicht weil
fast nirgends in deutschland mehr
omikron grassiert inzidenz
2100 hier wie anderswo würden die
verantwortlichen gerne aufs tempo
drücken es läuft aber schleppend für die
zeit von weihnachten bis ende januar
hatte kanzler scholz 30 millionen
impfungen als ziel ausgegeben mit rund
17 millionen ist es nur gut die hälfte
geworden letzte woche wurden im schnitt
noch 350.000 dosen pro tag verkauft
tendenz fallend davon waren nur 31.000
erste impfungen weswegen es kinder bis 5
jahre nicht gerechnet noch rund 16
millionen umkämpfte deutsche gibt die
frage drängt also wie gefährlich ist der
nun omikron gerne wird zur antwort die
hospitalisierung rate bei corona fällen
herangezogen
aber genau die verschwimmt gerade wir
sehen momentan in den stark betroffenen
bundesländer berlin bremen und hamburg
das so 60 prozent auf grund der kogit
erkrankung krankenhaus sind aber 40
prozent als begleit infektion beispiel
ein patient mit beinbruch erweist sich
im krankenhaus als positiv ohne symptome
in die statistik kommt er trotzdem als
hospitalisierte corona fall
außerordentlich unbefriedigend findet
der patientenschützer brauchen
tagesaktuelle daten darüber wie sie die
auslastung über alle stationen aus wer
kommt mit dem virus oder wirkung wegen
des virus in einen krankenhaus genauere
zahlen zu den omikron fällen halten
viele derzeit für extrem wichtig für die
patienten für die krankenhäuser
die infektionszahlen in deutschland
gehen weiter nach oben dabei ist eine
gruppe ganz besonders betroffen das
robert koch institut meldet 78
1318 neuinfektionen bieten 24 stunden
also fast 15.000 mehr als vor einer
woche die sieben tage incidents liegt
jetzt bei 1000
176,8 mit abstand am stärksten trifft es
die kinder bei einer inzidenz über 3000
das ergebnis viele schulen und familien
sind im ausnahmezustand eva schiller
berichtet
stäbchen in die nase test am tisch die
morgen routine in vielen familien die
müllers aus freiburg haben vier kinder
drei davon warten erkältet in zimmer
quarantäne auf einen pcr-test was wie
wann genau gilt eine bühler hat den
überblick verloren ich bin einfach
erschöpft ich kann nicht mehr ich habe
in den letzten zwei jahren viel
eingesteckt mit den kindern und das
gefühl der ersten monate der korona
pandemie wo man das für alle gemacht hat
und die maßnahmen man nachvollziehbar
das habe ich heute nicht mehr in
freiburg ist die inzidenz bei kindern
und jugendlichen auf über 4.000
geschnellt bislang hat diese grundschule
auf pool also gruppen tests gesetzt
damit ist jetzt schluss ball fast jeder
test positiv war wir haben von 500
kindern insgesamt die unsere schule
besuchen teilweise über 250 fehlende
kinder gehabt einmal auf warten auf
testergebnisse aber auch eben weil sie
in isolation sind wohl die kontrolle
verloren scheint wo die stiko keine
allgemeine impfempfehlung für kinder
ausgesprochen hat fragen sich viele
eltern wie riskant ist die schleichende
durchseuchung bei den infektionen mit
dem von den kindern ist es so dass die
meisten kinder natürlich in der milde
akute infektionen haben oder sogar
symptomatisch sind aber ich glaube im
moment kann noch niemand wirklich seriös
ausschließen dass dieser effekt nicht
auch noch langzeitfolgen trägers weil
wir dieses virus einfach noch nicht
genug kennen die bühlers haben weder
zeit noch nerven sich über solche fragen
gedanken zu machen augen zu und durch
ist ihre devise
sie merken es alle die preise steigen
weiter im januar lag die inflationsrate
bei 4,9 prozent im vergleich zum
vorjahresmonat schätzt das statistische
bundesamt im dezember waren es noch 5,3
prozent gedämpft wird der anstieg nur
durch die unterschiedlichen
mehrwertsteuersätze
hohe energiekosten und lieferengpässe
bleiben preistreiber
weil er und seine mitarbeiter während
des corona lockt downs mehrere partys
gefeiert haben sollen steht der
britische premier johnson seit wochen
unter druck heute nun kam der lang
erwartete untersuchungsbericht zur party
gate affäre darin ist die rede von
führungsversagen und schweren
regelverstößen aus london andreas stamm
wochenlanges warten zu ende auf einen
bericht der das schicksal von boris
johnson besiegeln sollte und er nun eine
party kultur trotz lockdown im zentrum
der macht attestiert
ich entschuldige mich für die dinge die
wir einfach falsch gemacht haben und
dafür die mir mit den vorwürfen
umgegangen sind ich habe verstanden und
werde es richten
die chance dazu kurioserweise die seit
kurzem laufende polizeiliche ermittlung
auf rücksicht darauf wurden details zu
zwölf partys den mutmaßlich schwersten
regelbrüche nicht veröffentlicht
darunter auch solche bei denen johnson
anwesend war ein direktes versagen des
premiers deshalb erstmal fehlanzeige
der prämie verkauft uns alle für dumm
die die opfer gebracht haben verachtet
er er ist nicht fit sein amt zu
bekleiden seine verzweifelten
erklärungsversuche haben alles nur noch
schlimmer gemacht
die hoffnung johnsons der ärger könnte
sich legen die polizei mit wochen
brauchen in denen er um seine fraktion
werden kann die noch nicht über johnson
schicksal entschieden hat was fragen
zeigen etwa die seiner vorgängerin und
parteifreundin
entweder hat der premier die regel nicht
gelesen oder er und sein umfeld sie
nicht verstanden oder sie dachten
jährige gelten nicht für sie was davon
war
bei einer seiner berüchtigten auftritte
bei denen johnson selbst hand anlegt
zeigt sich der premier heute
zuversichtlich kämpferisch ob ihm party
geld doch noch überrollt die
entscheidung ist erstmal vertagt
nach syrien dort leben die menschen seit
mehr als zehn jahren bürgerkrieg unter
schwierigsten umständen die jüngsten
zahlen der uno zeigen fast drei viertel
der bevölkerung leidet unter akutem
nahrungsmangel noch schlimmer ist die
lage in den flüchtlingscamps dort
vergrößern kälte und schnee noch das
elend über ein lager nordwestlich von
aleppo berichtet unsere korrespondentin
goalie datei
kinder sammeln den schnee unter aus
trinkwasser zu machen seit tagen haben
sie hier keine hilfslieferungen mehr
bekommen in der zeltstadt alma hatte im
nordwest syrien hat der schneesturm die
zelte fast weggeweht
abu ammar aus aleppo ist 71 und seit
fünf jahren ohne bleibe mit plastiktüten
schützt er seine füße vor wasser und eis
ein paar meter weiter eine allein
stehende mutter deren zelt um drei uhr
nachts über ihr und den kindern
zusammenfiel und ihr weniges hab und gut
in 1 1 vor
ich versuche alles zu sammeln alles was
ich finde plastiktüten papier pappe nur
um meine kinder warm zu halten alles was
wir tun können ist unsere kleidung zu
verbrennen
das leben in zelten fordert opfer
mehrere vertriebene starben in den
vergangenen tagen war die notdürftig
zusammengebauten öfen in den zelten
explodierten
mehr als 1,7 millionen syrer hier leben
in baracken oder zelten und sind auf
lebensmittelhilfen angewiesen die winter
in der region werden immer härter aber
die vereinten nationen haben nicht
einmal die hälfte der erforderlichen
spenden erhalten
wir haben ein großes defizit seitens der
spende die internationale gemeinschaft
hat sich wir müssen es so sagen von
syrien abgewandt
für die vertriebenen ist es das elfte
jahr der krise in syrien und eine
politische lösung ist weiter entfernt
denn je
wenn sie den menschen in syrien helfen
wollen können sie das tun über das
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
das spendenkonto hat die bahn de 65 104
106 100 104 106 100 stichwort zdf
nothilfe syrien weitere informationen
finden sie unter spenden zdf.de und im
zdf text auf seite 8 190
überraschend das ergebnis der
vorgezogenen neuwahlen in portugal die
sozialisten von regierungschef costa
können jetzt mit absoluter mehrheit
regieren bisher war costa auf die
unterstützung mehrerer linker parteien
angewiesen das bündnis zerbrach jedoch
bei der abstimmung über den
haushaltsentwurf bei den wahlen
hinzugewonnen hat auch die
rechtspopulistische partei schicker sie
wurde drittstärkste kraft
jetzt zum sport norbert vier tage noch
bis zur eröffnung der winterspiele ein
großteil des deutschen olympia teams ist
bereits in peking eingetroffen ja und
erlebt dort extrem strenge
sicherheitsvorkehrungen denn die angst
der chinesen vor micr on ist riesengroß
teile der hauptstadt sind abgesperrt
das neujahrsfest ist der höchste
feiertag der chinesen familie macht das
was sich alle wünschen ein gemeinsames
essen aber ein teil der familie musste
in der heimat bleiben die enkeltöchter
haben seit corona beginn ihre oma nicht
mehr gesehen die behörden haben mir
erklärt wenn ich nach peking zurück
komme muss ich in quarantäne
da bin ich dann lieber nicht gefahren
das virus und die spiele bereitet den
verantwortlichen sorgen gestern wurden
28 einreisende positiv getestet außerdem
neun weitere die sich bereits in der
olympia- blase befanden auch außerhalb
der blase häufen sich die virus fälle
mehrere wohnsiedlung haben sie deshalb
in der hauptstadt dicht gemacht hinter
mir ist eines der viertel das in peking
abgesperrt ist es befindet sich knapp
ein kilometer entfernt vom vogel ist
dort findet in wenigen tagen die
eröffnungsfeier zu den olympischen
spielen in peking statt ein virus
ausbruch quasi vor der olympischen
haustür genau das wollten die
verantwortlichen vermeiden derweil
proben sie die eröffnungsfeier ein
junges china soll die welt erleben virus
frei und fröhlich so die hoffnung
ja was für ein handball krimi beim em
finale gestern abend in budapest
schweden besiegt titelverteidiger
spanien mit 27 26 und das durch ein last
second tor per siebenmeter
welch ein sportliches drama
überglückliche schweden feiern
ausgelassen ihren hauchdünnen sieg gegen
die spanischen titelträger
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein siebenmeter in letzter sekunde durch
den rekordtorschützen des deutschen
meisters thw kiel niklas egbert hat ein
ganzes land in handball euphorie
versetzt
danach gab es kein halten mehr trainer
grenzsoldat mit dem pokal in händen
südländische begeisterung bei den
spielern aus dem europäischen norden das
finale war ein sauberer letzter akt bei
dieser von corona überschatteten
handball ehe
das wassersport zeigen könnte 1000 war
schon das ganze wochenende stürmisch
heute kam vor allem in den
mittelgebirgen ordentlich schnee dazu
zum beispiel hier bei schongau aktuell
warnt der deutsche wetterdienst in
bayern und baden württemberg vor
weiterem starken schneefall und
schneeverwehungen
mehr dazu hat gleich katja hornuf das
heute journal um viertel vor zehn mit
christian sievers wir danken für ihr
interesse wünschen noch einen schönen
abend und sagen tschüss das machen wenn
sie machen alles gute ihm
[Musik]